- But you have spoken to a porn star.
- Yeah, who hasn't?
- True.
(upbeat music)
- Today I'm gonna be asking
my daughter questions
under a lie detector.
- I've been pretty honest with my son
and I hope he's been honest with me.
- That's cause I don't
really ask you any questions.
- Given that he is my stepson,
I am a little concerned
with what the truth might be.
(ominous music)
- Adam, have you ever skipped school?
- Yeah.
- He's telling the truth.
- Did you do this in high school?
- Yeah.
- He's telling the truth.
- First question, I'm
gonna keep it simple.
Have you been drinking enough water?
- Yes?
- He's telling the truth.
- Have you ever hung out with
someone that I didn't like?
- Yes.
- True.
- Who was the guy?
- Well there was some rebels
and then you tell me not
to hang out with bad people
and they happened to be smoking.
- The marijuana?
- The marijuana, and they offered me some
and I said, no thank you.
- When I asked you to do something for me,
and you told me you needed
the money to pay a bill,
did you spend that money on a bill?
- Yes.
- Not true.
(groaning)
- Have you taken any illegal substances
within the last two weeks?
- No.
- He's lying.
- No way, he's lying. (laughs)
- When I asked you
to reorganize the garage,
there happened to be Halloween costumes
that you really, really, really liked,
did you take them?
- No.
(groaning)
It's a lie detector test.
- They were so cute though.
- Did you quit your job
or did you get fired?
- I quit.
- He's doing bad.
- Do you have sex with friend of yours?
- No.
- True.
- Why not, Stephanie?
- I really been wanting
to ask you this one
a long time, too.
- I'm a bit nervous.
- When I baked cookies for
your sister's birthday party,
literally half of 'em came up missing
that your cousin Mike
came over and ate 'em,
but I never saw Mike come in, ever.
Did you eat those cookies?
- Yes, I did.
- That's true.
I wish she'd bake my cookies.
- Have you had any sexual relations?
- Yes.
- True.
- Was any of this
unprotected by any chance?
- Yeah.
- He's telling the truth.
- Oh, great, mom's gonna love this.
- Oh no she's not.
- Oh yes she is.
- Me being your stepmom,
you know I don't feel the
family vibe when I'm around.
You try to cover it up a lot, so
does your biological mom
like your stepmom, yes or no?
- Yes.
- True.
- Okay.
- See I told you.
- When then I gotta
cook some more cookies.
- Have you ever had any
relations with a porn star?
- No.
- True.
- Have you ever spoken to a porn star?
- Yeah.
- True.
- So let's hear about this.
- So we have a date
dash for the fraternity.
(recording fast forwarding)
- Agent.
A porn star.
- Yeah.
- It's sayin' he's lying.
- That was totally made up.
- Are you dating now?
- No.
- Havin' a tough time.
- What?
♫ Didn't even cross my mind
Oh, we're just talking.
And sometimes I go to
sleep or in the morning
just talking to him.
He has a girlfriend, that's bad.
- So today we just finished
the lie detector test
with my step son, Roland.
- Found out some very
interesting things about my son.
He actually has had some
kind of conversation
with a porn star that I didn't know about.
This should be very
interesting to hear more about
as we drive home.
- It was a great experience.
Because we know each other.
But with this test. (mumbles)
- Yeah I respect him
and hope he respects me too.
- I respect you dad.
Come here.
- Stop lying.
(tranquil music)